deve essere frustrante fare le
interviste essere costretti sempre a
pronunciare il nostro nome perché se non
unica grandi pensa enel titolo piu
grosso il nostro nome del vostro
e visto che dite che non ho tecnica vi
faccio pure un extra di giusto priva di
il nostro progetto di 100.000 biglietti
non accorciato il disco la terza auto a
forbici penso d'auto che sono bravo vero
fa male vero deve essere frustrante poi
reparti del raking da cui mi sono
allontanato fatte di risiko di gente non
appagata non come me l'ho appena saputo
che abbiamo venduto 300 milioni di
biglietti che abbiamo fatto il sold out
anche su marte giove saturno cultura è
saputo anche che trump e le dimissioni
perché sarà il nuovo presidente degli
stati uniti d'america
e tutto questo solo grazie a voi grazie
grazie grazie grazie a tutti voi
il singolo ancora numeri uno dei numeri
uno ma vai a cag a tutti mi sono
prefissato per un pochino in gover
ieri sera ho fatto schifo come sempre
bella dunque letto con il messaggio
buffi sui social
a quanto pare almeno quella che il
mullah curione cosa devo dire
aie parti della nave giusto innanzitutto
come cazzo pario sembri il cummenda sono
frustrato porco e nuovo dopo conduco il
secondo luogo di ieri mi hai visto nei
giocatori un [ __ ] o bastato uno
sguardo ma dove lo zio tieni stata china
perché vi sto impazzendo
allora tu ieri alla sfilata di moschino
è risaputo esattamente davanti a me non
mi hai mai neanche lontanamente guardate
e se vuoi un sacco di testimoni c'è
reale break che era seduta vicino a me
c'erano i modelli mentre sfilavano se il
fuoco articoli loro crown stadio guardan
e comunque tu che sei l'unico babbo che
nelle sfilate con un bodyguard
recuperato in faccia a meno e fiato il
[ __ ] io avrebbe alzato lo sguardo si
abbassa lo sguardo è solo perché mi
arrivi al cazzo al cazzo è capito al
cazzo mi piglia chi cura chi tempo con
la tua fidanzata o non rompere i
[ __ ] a noi sfigato
oddio l'ho fatta bene ovvio troppo in
parte poter accorgono di tutto finto
nodi ci speriamo
se devo però grande idea sul giro secco
attivisti vendiamo